the number three Republican in the House
of Representative Steve Scalise is in
critical condition shot by a man with a
rifle during baseball practice cell
phone video captured the scene yesterday
Alexandria Virginia the group of GOP
lawmakers were practicing for tonight's
charity game against Democrats four
people were shot including House
Majority Whip Scalise of Louisiana he
was rushed to the hospital in a medevac
helicopter for emergency surgery doctors
say that a bullet tore through Scalia's
abdomen breaking bones and damaging
internal organs President Trump in the
first lady Melania Trump visited Scalise
in a Washington Hospital last night the
White House says the president sat at
his bedside and spoke with his family
mr. Trump also met Capitol Police
Officer that crystal Greiner she was hit
by a bullet in the ankle as she returned
fire lobbyist Matt mica and
congressional staffer Zach bars were
also shot
Capitol Police Officer David Bailey and
Congressman Roger Williams were injured
the gunman James Hodgkinson died after
police shot him several times the
shooting happened in a public baseball
field about five miles from the US
Capitol the gunman approached from the
third-base line while more than 30
people were practicing Jeff Pegues is at
the crime scene with new details on this
investigation Jeff good morning good
morning we're about 50 yards away from
that third-base line and from here you
can really see what the gunman was
seeing except 24 hours ago that baseball
fill was filled with Republican
congressman when the gunman who was
heavily armed opened fire
gunfire pierced the air 4:10 a ghen
izing minutes as james Hodgkinson opened
fire US Capitol Police Officers part of
House Majority Whip Congressman Steve
Scalise his security detail and
Alexandria police fired back witnesses
say Hodgkinson was armed with a handgun
and rifle when he approached a fence
along the third-base line and started
firing he never got on the field
representative Scalise standing on
second base was shot first in the hip
other lawmakers took cover in the first
base dugout
we could see Steve Scalise out into the
field Arizona Senator Jeff Flake waited
for an opportunity to help his injured
colleague I just ran low out to Steve
and and started putting pressure on the
wound investigators believe the 66
year-old Hodgkinson originally from
Illinois was out of work and had been
living in his van in the Alexandria area
since March the nearby Y was struck by
bullets locals saw him there frequently
he always had his laptop so he was
always with his laptop his laptop bag
kind of getting set up Hodgkinson
Facebook page shows that he supported
Vermont senator Bernie Sanders and did
not like president Trump it was a member
of a group called terminate the
Republican Party we are looking to glean
what we can from the contents regarding
his electrical devices that he owned
we're exploring all angles and we'll let
the facts take us where it goes
so did the gunman target someone
specifically on the baseball field or
was this just a target of opportunity
for him that's what investigators are
looking into among other things
congressman Jeff Duncan of South
Carolina says that before the gunman
opened fire he asked him if there were
Republicans on the field Jeff Jeff thank
you very much